was it a big deal with your family oh it
still is I talk about it online and my
parents and family do not like it they
think you're going to hell well they
think the LA's changed me and that's
really not the case I've never been more
myself it's just that I finally feel
free enough right to speak about it and
it's upsetting because it's so much
ingrained in the culture of being
Southern and being you know having that
southern family that you prayed for
every meal and you do this and you go to
church and whatever and it's just like I
don't subscribe to that anymore and it's
really tough for them so wow I don't
know it's an ongoing thing but I'm
happiest I've ever been so when you go
back and visit your family do you still
lock hands and say prayers and stuff you
just I play along just the vibe yeah
well because I'm not going to be like
I'm not doing that you know it's like
it's not gonna be an annoying [ __ ] yeah
and do you miss God's presence in a way
at all I missed the innocence of being
stupid right uh totally because it's
like there's an answer right it's like
you had I had for the longest time a
clear answer when there was a problem I
would pray and now it's just like well
well she is